I did I bombed, I feel horrible about it. I have a story. I have a great story,
but it had no ending. And Ari was like, all you need is a good ending.
Just don't worry about the story. Have a good ending. What's the story.
I had sex with my screenwriting teacher and, uh,
I worked at a New York film Academy and one of the teachers there,
it's a long story, but, uh, basically my showered and work in crown Heights.
So I was, I went like a week without showering. I smelled like. My boss said,
you gotta shower. You can't come in. And so I was going around, hold on,
hold on one second.
You literally do the shower to the point where people were like, yeah,
it was bad.
I couldn't do it because I was doing sets at night and then I'd wake up.
You know,
you gotta get home at three in the morning and you have to wake up at seven for
work. So, you know, we run out of there and we had no hot water.
We had no electricity in our apartment every now and then.
So it was snowing out. It was too cold to take a cold shower. And uh,
so eventually I put a bucking pot on the stove.
I boiled it in the dark and I was like,
I'm just going to take a horseback in the kitchen, get it over with the lights,
click on. After I done showering my roommate, cook stove,
top stuffing in the, in the pot.
So I've now covered in BEO and like spices and. And, well,
it was too late. I had to go to work. So I had to run out
Thanksgiving. So I remember getting on the train. It was the four train.
It was all, you know, I was the only white guy in black guys,
like standing over like sniffing me
stuffy. I put a pot on, I filled it with water and out. It was dark.
So I didn't know it was covered for corn nuts and cornbread
smell. Now I smell like a home cooked meal.
Yeah, it was brutal. Now I'm desperate. I get to work.
I'm covered in this film. And I got like a little parsley pieces on me.
So I go up to everybody and one lady, the screenwriting teacher,
Mrs. Fritz, we'll call her. I go, Hey, look, can I shower your place? She goes,
sure. I don't care. And I was like, Oh my God. She was like, kind of cute,
like 40, 40 year old quirky, weird earrings, big beehive kind of thing, hairdo.
And uh, she was like, yeah, sure. Just come over. But I'm having a dinner party.
It's at eight. So if you don't mind getting out of it, I was like, you got it,
whatever. So I get there like six, I bring a bottle of wine to be nice.
I get there. She has a beautiful apartment in Brooklyn,
all like a spread on the table.
Just crazy set up dishes, glassware, the placemats. And I'm like,
Oh my God. She's like eight things going on. The stove bubbling. I'm like,
Oh my God, she's really doing this. So I get in, I go, Hey, look,
I'll take a shower. I'll be out of your hair. No problem. She goes, sure, sure.
We'll have a glass of wine. We don't really know each other.
I have a glass of wine. We have two glasses of wine, three last one.
We're talking about life and love and philosophy. We're going at it.
And I was like, look, it's it's seven, 10. I gotta get in that shower. She goes,
all right. All right. Well, are you hungry? And I'm like,
I guess I'll have a bowl. She made paella. I was like, yeah,
I haven't eaten good. In three weeks. I'll take a bowl of pious.
And now I'm eating the pie. We have another glass of wine. I'm like, Hey look,
lady at seven 30. I got to get the hell out of,
you're having a dinner party at eight. So she's like, all right. All right.
So I get in the shower and I'm hammered at this point.
I meant like six glasses of wine. And we're being in the shower,
washing my body and be like, this is so nice. And then I go,
am I going to this woman now? What are you kidding? Get out of here. It's,
you know, 20 minutes. So people show up.
So I got out the shower and I was like seven 48. You know, I'm like scurrying,
like, all right, I gotta go. Thank you. And she goes, I have one more glass.
I'm like, all right. And she's like, let me give you a tour of the apartment.
We're walking around our apartment. She's showing me knickknacks and whatever.
Now we're standing up on her couch looking at a painting on the wall. And, uh,
we're both looking at, we were like face to face and she goes, uh,
you know what? And I go, what's that? She goes, I want you to come in my face,
swear to God. I want you to come in my face. And I go, all right.
And now we're just going at it. We're on the floor,
rolling around knocking coffee tables over and all this just. And, uh,
she pulled the string or something and all the lights went out in her apartment
and we're just going at it. And it was nighttime, just hot, dark sex.
I wake up the next morning, there's blood everywhere. She was,
she was on her period. And I mean, I just didn't notice it because of the dark.
It was just beat red crime scene thing.
And I had worked the next morning. So I just had to like,
so I went from being the cleanest I've ever been to now I'm covered in uterine
lining. So I had to just put on clothes and go, go to work. And, uh,
I remember on the way out, she was like, don't you tell anybody? And I was like,
all right, I won't. And I, of course I told everybody right when I got there.
But, uh, yeah, that was it. That was my story. Right.
I should have done the podcast, you know.
The late night. Why did I do that? Yeah. Why,
why did I go on Carson daily when I could have just how many
late nights have you done? 12. I think. Wow. And all of them bad.
Some really they're all funny.
I'm good. No, I had my last one was rough and I lost sleep over it.
I'm like punching walls in a hotel room in Sacramento. Like,
why did I pick that joke? Why did I do that?
Why am I in Sacramento? No, I feel, I know what you mean. Uh,
when you feel like you do a set that you're bummed about, or yeah, I get it,
but I I'm not placating. I would, I would not mention it,
but I truly think I haven't seen you have a bag. Bad set on.
Hi. Hey, I appreciate it. I appreciate it. I did one.
So I did my half hour comedy, central special, whatever that was bad.
That was bad. Cause I had a, I got a virus called H pylori and I was like,
I gotta change the date. They're like, we can't change the date.
So I had to do it. If you look on the internet, I'm puffy. I'm like,
my face is this big wedding. Laurie,
it's a virus you get from eating feces.
And I ate some fat chicks and Wisconsin. And uh,
I guess I got some fecal matter in me and uh, totally shut me down.
Wow. I was like, my tongue was sheet white.
I was spitting up like Hawks of whatever my, I was water.
I had a stomach ache. I mean, I was weak. It really got me.
That was cheese had chicks. I know, I know she didn't wipe enough. I assume.
I mean, I think even when I went back there, she was like, you're crazy.
You're taking your life in your hands and you a big eater. I, you know, it was,
it was like six years ago when it was like just, Oh,
and it just started raining. It was a trend. Yeah. It was a trend.
And I wanted to show like, Hey, I'm down. I'm pro women, you know,
I'll eat your. Yeah. That's true. Religion jeans on.
And you were all with the hip trends. You have affliction shirt. And like,
I mean that pal, you got that right. Whenever it comes around, I'm going for it.
Yeah. So you learned your lesson now. I learned my lesson. I came up,
it looked like I had a, like a candy Apple.
I was covered in chocolate and a boy, I learned my lesson now.
I only kids' asses. Right? Yeah. It's gotta be clean.
I get a baby wipe in there because they've just been cleaned. Right, right.
Exactly. After tub time. Is that what it is?
Tough time for nap hour two.
And then I look and then I put baby powder on it.
I could go on all day about a statutory.
Reading it.
I was reading an article this morning about gender differences and stuff.
It was actually a book review. And I thought, and the,
the conclusion that Orica was, well,
we're more symbol than we are different as human beings, men and women.
It's like, no kidding. Yes. We,
we are just about exactly the same creatures with these distinct. Yes.
Yes.
There's some distinctness qualities biologically that just are jut.
We have a bigger corporates callosum. We have to, they have bigger clothes.
They have a better brain. They have better brains. They live longer.
They have eggs.
Yeah. Know, there's clear differences. Yeah.
No, there are differences in it. And it has an effect.
Now we're much more alike than we are different. Sure.
Except where we're different, which is.
And we're different and it's okay. And I like the differences.
I like a hips and a small waist and a big nipple in a, you know,
a bald vet talking about me that way. Anyone else hard?
So, so.
No, I mean, you still gotta be a comedian at the end of the day. So talk,
tell me about when you got caught, how did you get, Oh boy, it was brutal, man.
It was, uh,
like I phones were still kinda new and I was in the shower and I was always on
edge, you know, like I got an, almost caught like 800 times,
but gotten out of it cheated a lot. Yeah. Pretty much every weekend. Yeah.
It was bad. Cause we weren't, cause we were, we were sick of each other,
but it was still like you shouldn't cheat and uh,
almost got caught a bunch and uh, I would just deny, deny, deny.
And then I'm in the shower one day. Everything's going great, good relationship.
Birds are chirping sun's out. And I'm showering up whistling.
And my phone lit lights up on the coffee table.
She's watching TV and a naked picture pops up.
And it's some blonde chick that I banged, who knows where. And uh,
she, I know passcode then, cause it was kind of a new phone and I,
she opens it up and starts reading the thread and it was like, well we did this.
And when we did that and it was so hot and I want to do this again.
I want to gargle that and suck on this and swallow that and all and just be
saying like I can't wait to do this again and pull that and yank that and fix
this. And uh, so the bathroom door kicks open.
She pulls the curtain back and I remember being like, Hey, coming in.
And uh,
she just showed me the phone and it was the picture of the naked girl and to
drop the phone in the tub and I'm like, Oh. So I grabbed the phone,
I jumped out naked. I'm just like in the living room, like, Hey, come on.
What are you crazy? Get out of here. No, no she's not her. And she's like,
I read the whole thing. you. I knew I knew it. I knew it. And um, you know,
you're naked when you're naked, you look, you look like an idiot, you know,
you're naked and wet. It's like the flip-flop serum. Oh yeah, there you go.
Was it after that? And then we tried to work it out, but it was never the same.
And six months later was done and I, sorry,
we lived together and I just moved out and I was like, keep the place.
I paid half the rent. Just try to be a good guy out of guilt.
And I just couch surf for like a year. Yeah. I everything in that year. I mean,
I, uh, I banged a chicken, a homeless shelter.
I was going on the road as much as I could. It was a
crazy story. I was a, I met a girl to show, I got her number.
We met up like a week later,
I went to a bar called alligator lounge where you get a free pizza with every
drink. So I met up,
met up with his girl and she's just wolfing down these pizza slices,
putting them down. She was like a cute blonde chick. And uh, I was like,
you all right? She's like, Oh, I gotta be honest. I'm homeless. And I go, what?
I'm homeless. So, uh,
we started bonding on the homeless thing and then she told me she's in a shelter
and I'm like, Oh, so we're making out, we're making out.
And then she pulls me away and goes,
wouldn't it be crazy if we went to my shelter and I was like, yeah, yeah,
go back to Megan. I'll go back and make an out pounding, booze, pounding booze.
Before I know it. We're in a cab on the way to the shelter.
And that's a funny moment by the way, being in a cab to a homeless shelter.
So we get there it's way out in Brooklyn, big stone building. And she's like,
I just realized they're not going to let you in. It's pretty regulated.
You know? So, uh, this has guy in the front,
you have to like be buzzed into this huge gate, big metal gate that slides open.
He goes, ah, you know, so, uh, she has this big hobo key to the shelter.
It's like a key with a, like a hubcap on it. And uh, she's like,
maybe you could go in and just act like you own the place going with the sh the
key and just walk right in and you won't have to sign in. I was like, all right,
that's that's good. So I go in, I go up homeless, you know,
tough riding the rails and I'm swinging the key. And the guy's like, yeah, yeah,
whatever. It's four in the morning. And uh, she just walks in and goes, Hey,
I'll sign in. Cause she's actually there. So they know her. So she goes,
whatever you do, don't get caught. I'm on the third floor on the women's floor.
You get caught on the women's floor. You'll go to jail. Cause like, you know,
I can't go up and rape women, bunch of hobos up there, you know?
And I remember I walked in and it was this big pit. It was just a big floor.
And it was full of people on cots. People in sleeping bags, people crying,
people, screaming, people like kind of wrestling. It was, it was wild.
Babies crying was crazy.
And I go up to the third floor and I run to her room and I opened the door,
swing the door open, and it's got two cops on the wall,
jail style stains on the walls, just cracked window. And I was like,
Oh my gosh. She comes in like 10 minutes later, we have crazy hobo sex.
We go at it. Thank God. I had a rubber who knows where she's been. And uh,
the next morning I, this crazy like beer,
I had to get out of me like booze. So I had the big stomach and I was like,
I got a page. Like you can't go to the bat. You'll get caught. And I go, Oh,
I got to go. It's an emergency. So I get the key. I run to the bathroom.
I'm peeing. And a girl comes in, I'm in the stall.
A girl comes to the bathroom like, Oh. So I have to sit down and pee, you know?
So she doesn't know, I'm a guy and she just dropping soup cans in there. I mean,
this girl next to me, hobo.
And I just pull my pants up and get the hell out of there.
I give her a key back. I said, thanks. Thanks for nothing. I run home. That's,
it was wild. Yeah. That's insane. Yeah. Brave sucks.
It's rarely brave. You know,
talking about how rape is cool is very brave and people go,
how could you say I'm like, I'm not saying it is. I'm saying it's brave.
I'm not saying you'd get ruined. I'm not saying it's a great, it's awesome.
I'm saying.
It's very brave. Yeah. Yeah. You're dancing on a.
Line. Yeah. But we we've ruined that word. And uh, yeah. Comedy,
it turned into some kind of like agreeance off at some point.
And I feel like we're getting out of that.
Yeah. This, the swing is happening, especially because people, when you tour,
they tell you how bad they just want to talk and have a good time. Right.
They don't go. Nobody goes to a club for a political lesson. Yes.
Nobody goes to like, feel correct about the world.
They go there to escape the that they feel about their workplace every day and
the things that they're not supposed to say and do, and there you go to go,
Oh it. We can just, I can let it burn. And this guy's going to help me,
let it burn the gasoline to be like, let's it now at light it up.
Yeah, exactly. I mean,
it's like you go to the Midwest and you talk to some guys on stage talking about
like how we need to help these people. And they're like, dude, I work in a mill.
I hit my wife almost a minute ago. Like just please give me a yuck them up.
And you keep making this not funny.
I'm gonna hit her again right in front of you. That's what's going to happen.
I'm on my 15th, bud, bud heavy. So you're to blame. You ought to blame pal.
And also I just see jokes as the shell of a puzzle.
I don't see it as like this feeling Z thing.
Like I have a joke in my act where I say, it's gotta be hard to be a kid.
Now we, we were so lucky as kids. Uh, I used to do it in your, your, your,
a tour there. When I'd say, uh, back when we were kids,
you had not care of the world. You run to the car and yell shotgun.
Now the only time a kid yells at are now is in a classroom. And people are like,
Oh my God. I'm like, Oh, to me, I just see shotgun, shotgun, that word,
the joke clicks. That's it. I don't see the whole inner webbing of, uh,
people dying and feelings and parents who lost kids. I don't have any of that.
To me. It's just the puzzle.
I had a joke where I would say where I would say we were at,
we had to go to George's choir concert. And it was like four hours long.
And the joke was, I wrote it the night, the night we went to the choir concert,
I then left to do a spot. After the choir concert, I saw,
I just sat through a four hour car concert and everyone was like, Oh,
I was like, yeah, where's a school shooter when you need me.
That's funny.
I mean, I still to this day and it's like, I laugh.
I tried to explain this to someone. One, I go, what.
You find funny. I also find funny, but what I find funny,
you won't always find funny things that make me laugh or like really when you're
not supposed to laugh, like, do you remember?
I could not stop showing you guys the Louis CK parent video.
Oh man. We were dying. Laughing
because he was not trying to be funny.
And that's when people are in their course. Of course. Yeah.
That was comedy gold. It was when he goes in,
he goes to this famous comedian was [inaudible].
I could not stop laughing at that. And I go, I know that this kid lost a child.
I can't imagine the pain and grief he's gone through.
I can't imagine the anger he had when he saw Louie joking about it. Of course.
And that all of that coupled by him,
inadvertently being very funny and what is not meant to be fun.
I ju it's like up makes me laugh today. I was just, I just said this today,
we got a new puppy and I was cuddling with it. And I go,
and I was just loving this puppy. I mean, this puppy cuddles so hard.
It, it is almost, I've never seen anything like it. And I go,
someone's had to their dog. Like, that's great. Like I can't,
I can't say that to like my wife's friends get it. They just would be like,
what the? That all the time I'll sit there and go.
You think pedophiles that little girls make fun of pedophiles and little
boys, like, look at these gay pedos, you know, homo. And I'm like, to me,
I'm like, that's an actually interesting thought to me. You know,
I'd actually like to have a debate about it, but people go, what the? Holy.
But like, to me, that's something let's, let's let's dig it.
Like this broad. What do you think? Dr. Joe? Well,
the do the farts pull the out. Thanks. A lot.
Hope to hear for them. Have a great show.
Yeah. So, um,
your mom's house listeners and viewers have spent a lot of time. Oh,
is that what? This contemplating? Very weird stuff. Yeah.
Cogitating on the strange, well, there's no answers for these things, right?
So here's the deal.
So gas forms within the colon because of the bacteria.
It's just forming in there. And it's, if you look at an x-ray of the colon,
it's just all over the place. It's not doing anything.
And your colon is doing this, moving everything through your colon,
pushes everything through dialysis. And when it gets down into the ampulla look,
those extra, those pictures of woe lens and Gammy. The one down there,
the second on the bottom, right? The one on the left there,
the one from the lab that you're getting, that's a lot of gas.
That's a lot of gas in there and that'll kill a Jew. Good.
Uh, and, uh, that's off like that one,
uh, gas chamber, uh you're on like grassroots,
like we're going to help the downtrodden. Yeah.
And so they weren't making money. Like they do some pro bono. And uh,
what kind of attorneys were they? They were civil, you know, slipping a Walmart.
Yeah. Bad people. Yeah. Bad. And they hated it. They were both miserable.
They've told me openly, like I hate my job. I feel like every day.
And I was like, ah, but they raised a good kid. Well, we'll see. I mean,
I was a up, you know, juvie and a lot of juvenile hall. Oh yeah.
A couple of times. A lot of, uh, what do you call it? Vandalism. What? Graffiti.
Graffiti. I had a tag name. What was your tag name?
My tag name was stank. S T a N K. Yeah.
Which is still embarrassed about should be that's it? That is embarrassing.
Yeah. It was all of my notebooks and we would break stuff.
We would do this thing.
We would drive down the street and knock off side view mirrors. Oh yeah.
I love that. That was fun. That was like a pastime mailboxes. No,
not really mailbox. It was more side view houses. We egged houses.
We teepeed, we, uh, we ran a muck. You did it all. Oh yes.
Isn't egging houses. I realized this the other day.
It's like the most white privilege thing to throw good food at a home. Oh yeah.
You're throwing food at property. It's like just such a privileged person.
Ruining a privileged person's afternoon. Good plan kind of abortion. Yeah.
You're really thinking about it. Well, that's, I'm pro choice.
So that's why I'm pro choice. Same here. You should,
you should be embarrassed about stuff like that because we all have that.
Like I thought I could rap when I was, Oh,
that's I never got into that stuff because I grew up in a black neighborhood.
So I had enough blackness inside my.
Like you had to kind of seek it out and rebel. Maybe. No, no, I loved it.
I loved it so much. Wow.
Just out of curiosity, did we party together in Seattle? Yeah.
Yes. I might know that it was Portland actually. Yeah. We went to a strip club.
God, that was a great night. And you, I was so hung over. I'm a Rogers was like,
I'm not drinking for four days. I'm so hung over. And you were like,
do this shot. I was like, I can't. And you're like do it. I was like,
if I do the shot on my puke and you're like, do it and I did it and I puked,
but I kept drinking. And then I saw you at the airport at 6:00 AM.
And you had appeared your hand still drinking. Yeah. I was very impressed.
Yeah. That's a, yeah. Well that that's my Mo I, I can't, I,
I can reward myself. I get up early.
Like I got off stage at like one yet. Yes. Two days ago,
Saturday night or Sunday morning, my car picked me up at four and I said,
okay, if I can get like two hours sleep, then I'll go.
I'll get myself a cocktail. And then, and then, and I was like,
and then that'll right. The boat immediately share a little bit of buzz.
I'm like, Oh, I'm fine. And so.
Have you tried motive pure? Have you heard of this? Oh,
I did drunk history and I was talking to the guy who ran, I forget his name,
but, uh, Derek, Derek waters. And he was like, I was like, look,
I can't wait to do the show, but I like got to let you know,
I get the worst hangovers. Like two-day hangovers, they're brutal.
And he's like, Oh, I got a thing.
It's called motive pure it's they give it to athletes to stay hydrated.
He's like, I haven't had a hangover in four years. I'm like, Oh my God.
He's like, get them on Amazon go nuts. So I ordered a bunch. I do drunk history.
I drank like a third of a bottle of scotch. I really go after it.
And a bottle of scotch. Is that a lot? I don't know. I drank it.
It was like a gold label,
but I drank a lot of it more than half and I really went hard.
Cause I wanted to be funny for the show. And he's like, here's your motive?
Pure. And it's like a little shot. I drank it. That's it? Yeah.
Buying a box right now. I drank it. Can get it by tomorrow. There you go.
So that'll be good for your hangover tomorrow, but I put it down and I wake up.
I've never been more hung over at puke. My brains out. I was blood. I was,
I was, uh, I had a gig that night. I had to cancel the gig.
I couldn't get out of bed. I was like regarding Henry. I was in bed.
I couldn't move my toes. I couldn't get out of bed. It was brutal. Oh my God.
That, that, that. I think you got to like drink a lot of it or something,
but I overrode it with the scotch, but try,
it might like it didn't work for me. Do you still party? Oh yeah.
I had a crazy weekend in Columbus. Great city. Funny bone.
Yeah. Yeah. Great.
Oh yeah. I just saw her. I think I was there and I saw your name on the.
Oh yeah. Yeah. I had a blast. What a fun town.
They call it the Austin of the Midwest. Yeah. Yeah. Which I dunno.
Seems a little weird, but uh, good times. Great.
Clubs. Have you got a little Liberty township?
I'm doing that in two weeks. Yeah.
I was just there. And uh, I'll tell you the one thing you're gonna, I,
that I think every comic notices, their sound system is amazing.
It's the best sound you've ever had. Great. It's like you hear yourself,
but it's not overwhelming. Yeah. I, I love those,
those two clubs because you can pack them out and you can make like legit money.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And I hate doing the meet and greet after,
but I just suck it up and I do it. And you get a couple of numbers and yeah,
it's a, it's a cakewalk out there in the Midwest. You leave this weekend.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Did I? I mean, it's,
you know, some curly haired, new Yorker shows up and you look,
you look exotic out there. It's a good time. It's fun.
So yeah. That's what, uh, what soda was like. Yeah.
Mark's numbers are through the roof.
Well, I went hard, man. You know, I was,
I never got laid in high school and all that.
So I just put my focus into that and getting laid. It's a real art form.
It's a beautiful thing. Yeah. Yeah. So I just got good at it.
It was like open mics.
I would got shut down for months and months then got better and better.
And then you get on Twitter.
I mean a Tinder and Bumble and that's a game changer,
a hundred percent true story. Dan. That's a funny guy. He with him. Pretty good.
His name was Lil Duvall. Um,
mine is, uh, just say pancakes. All right.
I got lost in upstate New York and I couldn't figure out I didn't have a
smartphone. I didn't know where I was going.
So I see this black girl in the car and she was really pretty.
And I go up to her and I talked to her. I'm like, Hey, can you help me out?
And we kind of flirting a little bit. Like we're like hitting it off.
And she's laughing. I'm zigging and zagging.
And this guy drives by in a truck like a hillbilly guy and yells out pancake
lover. And uh, I was like, Jesus, man. Yeah.
I just met this girl and you're gonna use the L word already
slow down. You know, that's an important word. We should bury that word, blah,
blah, blah. Oh yeah. Maybe I could bring it back. I don't know.